en lo que el gobierno francés llama un
equilibrio entre endurecer el control de
la inmigración y mejorar la integración
un nuevo proyecto de ley introduciría
una serie de medidas para ajustar el
sistema de inmigración francés según las
estadísticas de expulsiones Francia
recibe 120.000 órdenes de expulsión de
inmigrantes al año pero debido a los
largos procesos de apelación solo
deporta al 10% de ellos lo que ha
suscitado las críticas de la extrema
derecha el ministro del interior francés
ha declarado que el proyecto de ley
agilizará el proceso y presionará a las
personas a las que se les ordene
marcharse cualquier extranjero que
solicite la residencia de larga duración
en Francia tendrá que demostrar que
domina un nivel mínimo de francés Es la
primera vez que se exigen pruebas
formales de lengua para obtener la
residencia
la propuesta También incluye medidas
para los inmigrantes indocumentados que
trabajan en sectores bajo presión como
la restauración la hostelería y la
construcción si han vivido en Francia un
mínimo de tres años y trabajan en un
sector con escasez de mano de obra
pueden solicitar el estatuto de
trabajador legal además para paliar la
escasez de personal en los hospitales
franceses los trabajadores sanitarios
extranjeros cualificados podrán obtener
una tarjeta de residencia especial y
traer a sus familias Se espera que la
legislación se presenta en la asamblea
nacional antes del verano